one of the risks that I fear because
they are not properly secured securing
our borders and dealing with the crisis
of illegal immigrants flooding into this
into the system is
these people who are coming in do not
recognize our government governments
fall when the people do not have
confidence in those governments so if
you look at let's go back to we talk
about Lexington Lexington and Concord
and the American Revolution
when the when the crown said
Massachusetts is in a state of rebellion
and here's what you have to do the
militias outside of Boston says we don't
recognize you and we're going to do
whatever we want because there was no
confidence that they could do anything
and there was a willingness to reject
them let me put it this way if a guy
walks up to you wearing a clown suit and
says I'm from clown division on your uh
put your hands against the wall you'd be
like what no clown division hands
against why would you put your hands
against the wall for someone showing the
clown division badge and they have a big
clown hair and nose and they go you'd be
like bro is this a joke I don't know who
you are and you have no authority over
me